okay let's hear from a few more people
you can join the discussion on our
discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to marcus
from manitoba marcus you are on the air
hello david
uh hello
my question for you is
why do you think
uh
all of these self-identified left-wing
populists
a prominent left-wing populists
online and in real politics
have have tended to go in
similar direction over the course of
their political careers i'm thinking
people like
your friend and mine tulsi gabbard and
jimmy dore
and matt taibi
tending to go in a similar direction of
you know
kind of being receptive to
russian
friendly towards russia
kind of
repeating or tending to be
promoting promoting kind of narratives
similar to
the kind of things that we see on the
right coming from trump and such
why
do you think this is what what what is
causing this
you know i really i really don't know um
i don't think there is one answer like
for example
if we were to just say
these faux left wing populists
are doing this because of money for
example
um
maybe maybe to some degree
for some of them i don't know that there
really is that much money in it so i
don't i don't think that's really the
explanation
um
maybe it's for attention i mean
attention is linked to money maybe some
of them are like you know i i just kind
of blend in
if i just do actual leftism so i'm going
to do this kind of wacky reactionary
faux populist thing maybe that's kind of
a factor
another part might be some of them might
actually
have been confused about what their
actual politics are and maybe they
thought they were on the left and then
they realize
they're actually kind of not and they
make that more clear in their public
pronouncements um i i don't think
there's one answer but it is weird
because it's like you could just say
you're on the right you don't really
have to claim to be on the left but have
reactionary positions you can just and
look tool c is being welcomed at cpac
now so clearly there's space for them on
the right you know i i don't know that i
have one answer
well i do have uh
my own personal theories okay about why
this is yeah it may be controversial
given that i i know that
uh you know previous callers have voiced
uh
opposing opinions about populism at you
know
i recall someone said something like uh
oh trump
why is trump called a populist trump
isn't a real populist right-wing
populism isn't real populism
i think that gets something
fundamentally wrong
it
sort of presupposes that
populists
or populism requires being honest about
your populist beliefs
i don't think it does right i think
populism is a rhetorical
tool primarily well or rather like there
are different definitions of populism
right no but i think you're right i mean
i've commented before
the reason
populist rhetoric can be so tricky
is that there can be any policy
underneath it and the populism itself is
not policy and like the great example
was
you know you could have
bernie and tucker
similarly saying we've got a real
problem here where the middle class is
being taken advantage of and we've got
to support the middle class we need to
make sure that legal infrastructure and
and all this stuff supports the middle
class bernie would have one solution and
tucker would be like and it's brown
people coming from mexico that are the
problem right so so i think that you're
getting exactly at what i've said for
years
yes i'm and i mean
i think there's a substantive difference
between
uh people who are both called populists
like bernie and tucker carl carlson
uh
or i don't think tucker has any plans to
well he obviously has no actual policy
proposals
uh that could solve the problems he's
talking about right whereas bernie might
although i'm also somewhat skeptical
that he is really all that pragmatic
or whatever i i still like bernie
sanders sure but
uh
i i do think that
uh
what unites them both is
and what what unites all strands of
populism is primarily the rhetoric that
he uses yes and i think so and here's
where there will be some who will
disagree with one of the things that
you're saying
there are some who will hear what you're
saying and they'll go well tucker's not
really a populist he's actually an a
privileged elitist right winger
but i think the point you're making is
there's really no such thing as a
populist populism is a is a rhetoric and
you've got to look at policy some people
would just disagree with you as to what
populism is is it policy or is it
rhetoric or is it both
well exactly and i would say furthermore
that it like
the very rhetoric of populism it is
defined by its def it's
it's creation of this dichotomy between
the elite and some nebulous category
known as the people both of them are
really nebulous categories and often
the populists themselves are coming from
elite positions this has been the case
since really ancient times yes populism
has been a strategy that's worked in
democracies
since democracy first came into
existence think of cleon in athens think
of julius caesar he was a populist
and
and
all of them or a lot of them do tend to
come from the elite classes and they
frame themselves as being sort of class
traders being like actually on the side
of you the people
uh when in fact often
it is just a rhetorical tool
uh
to allow them to gain position of power
yes i agree with you completely and
there are many in my audience who will
disagree but i really appreciate you
laying it out so clearly
thank you david all right there is
marcus from manitoba
dropping the hammer
in a serious manner